forever
happy Thursday everybody
you look fantastic even you over there
shirtless yummy so President Biden is
dead lasts when it comes to the
Democratic choice for president
I should read this prompter better
yep it's not just the right anymore
who's sitting the obvious about Joe even
Dems finally realized that Biden is
fossilized if he was fueled they would
refuse to burn him
the ultra liberal Washington Post
columnist David Ignatius is throwing in
the security blanket this week finally
admitting in print that Joe's too old to
run for re-election or to the bathroom
for that matter
if only he could admit that Joe was too
old to cut his own food but how daring
it's like admitting the ladies of the
view enjoy carbs
let's be clear this isn't an elderly
man's rapid slide into senility it's
about political operatives finally
conceding to biological and political
reality for those of you slow in the
uptake he's not just walking toward the
light he's trying to shake his hand
thank you and so after some throat
clearing about how great Biden has been
as a candidate and a president hang on a
second I'm trying not to vomit Ignatius
writes quote I don't think Biden and VP
Harris should run for re-election it's
painful to say that given my admiration
for much of what they have accomplished
of course it's painful Dave there
usually is discomfort involved when
talking out of your ass
but
he says that if Biden and Harris
campaign together in 2024 Biden May undo
his greatest achievement making all that
illegal money from China for his family
by pawning his name like it was a stolen
watch
so this just means being president is
his greatest achievement as presidents I
wonder what his second greatest
achievement is was it the collapse of
Afghanistan or blowing up Nordstrom too
honorable mention eggs cost six bucks
but really the most important thing
Biden did says Dave was keeping Trump
who kept Hillary from slithering back
into the White House I mean who needs a
president who puts this country first
right no wonder there were less murders
under Trump Ignatius calls Trump 2024
the nightmare of a Revenge presidency
but that's exactly what the Biden
Administration has been already they
don't care about how much worse your
life is with their party in charge this
is all about their political fortunes
and Trump would be their Misfortune
Ignatius also admits Biden's age isn't
just a Fox News Trope well thanks so
much Dave turns out we're not the only
ones who can count all the way up to 80.
and I like Joe we can do it without
dozing off
Ignatius took to MSNBC of course to
defend his surrender to the brevity of
human life
we're running out of time for there to
be a meaningful process of looking at
alternative candidates he has a moment
now where you ought to think about
whether he should say no to himself
about this fundamental question of
running again there's strong feeling in
the country it's bipartisan that when he
takes office at 82 he's too old to serve
a four-year term now that electronic
noise you hear isn't microphone feedback
it's Biden's Life Alert button giving
him the two-minute warning
okay
so is this just the Democratic party
getting Biden out of the way ahead of
the impeachment hearings he could take
more people down with him than the
Lusitania
wow that's that's a reference
yet they keep claiming there's no
evidence of wrongdoing sure and Jeffrey
Epstein killed himself
and coven came from a bat
and Brian stelter has never touched a
pringle
and Keith Olbermann has human friends
but if that were true about Joe why are
they suddenly admitting what we've all
known for years even before the 2020
election how do they benefit from
admitting that we were right all along
it's like they're pleading guilty to
avoid the trial and yes they're
pretending this is all their idea much
like Joe Biden's speeches you can
Gaslight people about a lot of things
like diversity is our strength or white
supremacy is our biggest domestic threat
or Corn Pop was a
you can lie to them about inflation in
foreign policy you can even say this
mouth-breathing hump is the smartest guy
you know
but you can't unold Joe Biden not even
with two dozen mothballs and a fresh
change of formaldehyde
he looks old he ax old he is old the
upside he still poops like a
two-year-old
but even though White House Press Corps
is catching on or rather they realize
they no longer need to pretend Biden is
mentally fit to be president hell it's a
stretch to pretend Biden is mentally fit
to beat John fetterman at checkers
damn roll it
the president has lied about being at
Ground Zero the day after the September
11th attacks falsely claimed he saw the
Pittsburgh bridge collapse I claimed his
grandfather died in the hospital days
before his birth what is going on with
the president is he just believing
things that didn't happen did happen or
is he just ran like making stuff up
see that's the problem with electing a
lifelong fabulous with creeping dementia
that's now in an all-out Sprint does he
even know what reality is anymore in
order to lie about it it must be hard to
remember a past that wasn't there to
begin with all these Dems aren't
suddenly admitting this inescapable
reality because it's the right thing to
do they're admitting it because like a
65 year old stripper they just can't
spin it anymore
it's to say it's the same reason Ferris
wheels won't take Chris Christie
and it's not just Joe it's Kamala other
columnists are also floating several
options to replace Harris including LA
mayor Karen bass Michigan Governor
Gretchen Whitmer and a used cocktail
napkin
heck even Pelosi when given the
opportunity to back come like can't help
but deflect
vice president Harris the best running
mate for this president
he thinks so and that's what matters and
by the way I think so she's very
politically astute I don't think people
give her enough credit do you think she
is the best running mate though she's
the vice president of the United States
or people say to me well why isn't she
doing this or that I said because she's
the vice president that's the job of
description
you don't do that much
yeah I still give her credit for being
able to move her face but
finally we agree the VP doesn't do crap
back to Joe there are plenty of 80 year
old Americans who are still mentally and
physically capable of handling the
presidency you got Clint Eastwood
William Shatner Steve Ducey
so kudos to these Dems for finally
admitting it they finally learned not to
put all your eggs in one casket
so it's no longer if he's out for 2024
it feels like when they should just give
him the gold watch and show him out
except he might mistake it for a bribe
and ask what Ukrainian prosecutor he
needs to fire
Vegas is smart they'll start taking bets
from viewers on what month he'll drop
out right Joe
no no no no no I'm not going anywhere
man and nobody's going to do anything
about it and you know why right because
I'm holding a little something
it's called Kamala insurance
I'd say you think I got low numbers to
take a look at a Harris poll
she's better Insurance than Flow from
Progressive
and come to think of it she wouldn't
look bad in one of them white pants
suits
laugh it up laughy Kathy
[Applause]
[Music]
come tonight's guests he's the only gym
I go to when I need to work out comedian
and co-host of the Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts show Jim Norton
at first you're infatuated then you're
assassinated former CIA operative and
host of the president's daily free
podcast my Baker
she's truly a Renaissance woman she has
scurvy and gets called a witch New York
Times best-selling author and Fox News
contributor
and since he retired from wrestling his
new passion is full contact Bingo New
York Times best-selling author comedian
former NWA world champion
Jim you are an astute political Observer
having worked on every major political
campaign since the early 90s I remember
your campaign slogan for Bill Clinton
sometimes the cigar is just a cigar
that's correct that was great and then
one you had for Obama which was can you
believe this guy Kenya
you people suck
I hate it when that happens it's hard
it's hard to follow a cigar joke
Biden I mean mean uh you know he's got
to step aside him everybody's kind of he
moves like one of those aliens they
brought into the Mexican Congress yes
it's just a catatonic old man I mean I
think the Democrats are just a bad
position what do you do it's like Trump
is very popular with Republicans and
Biden is just a mashed potato-brained
idiot you just gotta go so yeah that's
my pollute my uh astute opinion to say
pollute might just do the opinion he
stinks somewhere all right who do you
think is going to be the nominee
that's amazing you know Mike you're a
card-carrying member of the deep State
yeah you've planned every coup since the
1950s and even dated Marilyn McCoo and
Billy Davis Jr I did I did doesn't this
feel like to you an intelligence
operation they put the bat signal out in
Washington Post and NBC and MSNBC all
fell in line did you get the word I did
uh they ran the column David Ignatius
column passed me first
um and uh and look they there's no doubt
that he didn't uh kind of run this past
some Washington insiders right he's not
just gonna he's been there for so long
he knows what this would mean if he was
the only person saying this in in print
so he ran this pastor put it out there
and I would have agreed with Jim in the
past I would have said even a couple of
months ago yeah Biden's going to be the
nominee but I really believe they're
setting the table here and they they're
deadly afraid of Kamala Harris and the
only way to move her off the scene is to
have Biden step away right right then
they clear the decks and they get
somebody else in the only other thing I
would say quickly is have you ever
noticed that politics is the only
occupation where age doesn't matter
everything else we we retire CEOs from
major corporations in their mid 60s we
move out senior Military Officers uh
officials we we uh we retire Pilots
everybody has an age Point except for
politicians no I will argue that on
PornHub
there is a select thing that just caters
specifically to that really yeah that's
where I found you
[Laughter]
well so what what would be the acronym
then it's not it's not MILF obviously
because I'm a dude so obviously yeah
obviously
there's that one group video Baker's
Dozen but anyway yeah all right it's
actually it's it's that's there's 13 of
us which that's true I almost broke the
bed
cat isn't it funny how it takes
Democrats usually three years to tell
the truth I don't know I personally
loved the way that Nancy Pelosi handled
the question I actually loved it she was
like no no no since her job is to do
literally nothing she's really good at
it
you know Joe's happy with her so that's
all that matters it's like when you
introduce your friends to the new guy
that you're dating yeah and they're all
like he was nice yes which is what you
say when you mean ugly and boring
because it was anything else then you
could think of a better word than nice
and then they're like if you press them
further they're like well as long as
you're happy yes
that's the worst thing that's exactly
what she it was Savage but you could
never say it was Savage because she was
so nice about it yeah she's a she's a
pro and I mean that the best possible
sense Tyrus what if Joe doesn't go and
Dr Jill a pediatric neurosurgeon who
discovered penicillin
leads the resistance what do you do well
he's not gonna go otherwise he would
ever went yeah I mean cat hits this on
the head so many times and I feel like
I'm just stealing this from you but you
didn't say it so tough
it's not the number they keep saying old
old it's not old it's him he's done and
he's shot out he's finished doesn't care
what age you made him he was always
behind no matter what age he was in like
like look at his go back and look at his
history
you know they're they're like oh my God
he's telling lies have you not seen the
last 37 years he's lied about everything
he never stops lying that's the great
thing about him getting Alzheimer's he
doesn't have to remember yeah so it's
like he'll just make it up as he goes
that's I mean that's a brilliant point
because it it's all about the Acuity
everybody ages differently some age very
well some don't and he's an overachiever
yeah I will give him back yeah he is
aging phenomenally
he's possible Michael Jordan of Aging if
there was a medal or a championship for
aging that's the guy
all right
he's on the cover of Brian he's on the
cover of Malt-O-Meal and food you eat
without teeth that's your guy hey excuse
me but Malt-O-Meal is delicious oh
you're dead all right that was fun huh
all right up next did a famous Yankee
flap his gums and betray his baseball
Chum
if you'll be in the New York area and
like tickets to see Gutfeld go to
foxnews.com and click on the link to
join our studio audience
[Music]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else